vendredi soir et chaufouré au sein de
l'espace Saint-Quentin à montigy le
Bretonneux entre une quarantaine de
mineurs âgés de moins de 15 ans et des
policiers bilan une jeune policierre
blessé à l'œil dès samedi matin une
réunion s'est tenue entre le directeur
de l'espace Saint-Quentin Hervé deot et
le commissariat de Guy encour deux
personnes supplémentaires ont été
affectées à la sécurité du centre en
complément des cinq agents de sécurité
et les patrouilles de police renforcé
pendant ce weekend pour le directeur du
Centre c'est un épi phénomène mais qui
demande que l'on reste vigilant il
rappelle d'ailleurs que 140 caméras
surveillent le site commerce comme
parking des caméras qui viennent d'être
changé le centre commercial accueille 13
millions de visiteurs à
l'année